to get to this destiny to Lou cave we're
gonna need to go to nessus obviously and
then you need to fly to exodus black
alright cool
when you get to Exodus black we're gonna
head on over here might as well get your
Sparrow out assuming you have it you
don't you don't necessarily need to have
a sparrow to do this but it's a little
bit faster if you do it with a sparrow
so you're gonna go through this cave
which I'm kind of dubbing the blue cave
whoops so you're gonna
not get shot by these guys you're gonna
go through here and you're gonna end up
in this other cave which you can also
sum esperen and we're gonna continue
through this cave and we're gonna
essentially ride over yonder and then
we're gonna keep going through the cave
and then we're gonna keep going until we
get through this platform which is here
in the top right-hand corner
maite whoa oh yeah that's right sorry so
after you get teleported you're gonna
run this way and we're gonna go through
that portal I believe I actually could
have grabbed the chest just now when we
ran through it the first time but we're
gonna run through this portal and get
teleported here here's those jerks that
were shooting me earlier go ahead get
rid of them but you don't have to deal
with them they'll show up every now and
then so now I happen to have the Nessus
scouting map consumable open but now you
can grab this chest and the reason why
this is kind of the loot cave is because
you grab this chest you'll get a token
sometimes you'll get legendary engrams
sometimes you'll get a blue but anyways
after you do that you're gonna run back
this way can't summon our vehicle there
I think we can summon it back here let
me try one yeah
summon your Sparrow again
then you're gonna ride through the cave
and you're gonna hop off go back to that
platform
I should have my mind a multi-tool out
it actually helps if you want to speed
it up by adding or changing your armor
pieces to mobility but essentially
you're gonna keep running here and
basically you're just rinse and
repeating so basically you can keep
farming this chest every time now if you
don't have the necessary report there
are like multiple squats where the
treasure chest can be but my suggestion
would just be to have the scouting
report which you can buy from Kay so
basically you can just keep farming
coins which you can give to the vendor
or if you get lucky you'll get legendary
engrams so some of your sparrow again
and then we're gonna get through the
chamber of sky cave here pop off our
sparrow
and just rinse and repeat so yeah this
is basically the destiny - I guess new
loot cave and I'm gonna try a couple
more times and just so we can see if we
get the legendary Engram obviously you
know it doesn't always happen but one
can hope these ones for some reason this
chest just will keep respawning and so
it's like unlimited of chests I guess if
you want to do this now this is a little
mind numbing and it's definitely not for
everybody so I understand but if you
want to level up fast this is a decent
way to do it because you're gonna get
blues
or Purple's potentially so sometimes
it's back here as the map oh sorry it's
through this alley here so something
that's why this it really helps to have
the map it's only 5,000 glimmered to
have the map pick that loot up no
legendary ingram yet but that's okay
we're just gonna run back out again like
i said to make this faster if you have a
might a multi-tool that'll help you run
faster obviously because that's just the
perk if you have higher mobility gear
that's going to help you but basically
this is a destiny to loot cave the new
loot cave so do this at your own risk
obviously that's you know they're
probably gonna patch it i would assume
at some point but you know enjoy it if
you want to you don't that's fine too as
mentioned we have other ways and tips
that we've given you to kind of find
ways to farm like heroic public events
but this way basically just running a
loop
all righty so let's try one more time
and see if we get a legendary if not
we're gonna move on chess can sometimes
be there there's like multiple spots
where you'll spawn so obviously as
mentioned before there you go legendary
in game took us about five tries but hey
well is that really in time like a
couple minutes so yeah pretty awesome
like us if you need to get gear or if
you need to farm tokens you know just
run this loop on X's black in this cave
and I hope you enjoy it
thank you guys for watching this video
and I hope this loot cave gets you some
sweet precious purple engrams we have
more destiny to guys like this one in
the works so don't forget to hit that
sub button see you guys next time